bonjour à toutes et à tous cette vidéo
est un extrait du paléo news numéro 4
qui parle de l'homme de piltdown alors
comme c'est une vieille vidéo le son est
un petit peu usé mais je trouvais quand
même intéressant de la remettre sur le
devant de la chaîne tout simplement
parce que c'est un résumé assez succinct
mais complet de la sphère de l'homme de
piltdown et de ce qu'on en sait
aujourd'hui et notamment qui sont qui
est le coupable et qui était son
potentiel complice alors la sphère de
l'homme de piltdown c'est évidemment
celle qui est tout le temps mise en
avant puisque c'est l'imposture
scientifique la plus célèbre au moins
pour l'évolution humaine donc fatalement
c'est quelque chose qui est très qui est
radoter par les créationnistes et qu'on
se reprend sans cesse dans la face alors
moi pour les créationnistes qui
écouterait cette vidéo
j'ai juste un tout petit défi mais
vraiment très simple et très sincère
trouvez moi une seule imposture
paléontologique c'est-à-dire un faux
faux cils qui étaient fabriqués par des
paléontologues et qui était et des
bunkers par des créationnistes parce que
tous les fossiles que les créationnistes
accuse d'être des impostures bon déjà la
plupart sont des erreurs comme par
exemple archéo raptor c'était une erreur
d'interprétation
mais en plus systématiquement après ce
sont d'autres paléontologues qui ont
montré que c'était des impostures
ce qui prouve que la paléontologie est
une science auto correctrices il n'y a
pas de grand complot il ne peut pas y
avoir de grand complot parce que les
intérêts des paléontologues les uns par
rapport aux autres divergent trop
donc voilà ils sont trop contents de se
tirer dans les pattes les paléontologues
comme n'importe quelle discipline
scientifique ou n'importe quel être
humain sur terre d'ailleurs donc moi je
suis un grand défenseur de la théorie
qu'il n'y a pas de grand complot et il
va falloir me montrer cher
créationnistes qu'en fait il y en a un
avec les créationnistes sont là pour
nous le démontrer
on voit la trouvez moi un créationniste
qui un jour à des banques est une
imposture paléontologique bonne chance
et bon visionnage
pour la rubrique vintage nous revenons
en 1912 quand le paléontologue
britannique arthur smits woodward
annonce à la découverte d'un nouvel
hominidé par un amateur d'antiquités
nommé charles dawson dans la petite
ville d'angleterre de piles da cet
hominidé connu sous le nom de l'homme de
piltdown est célèbre pour être l'une des
plus grandes supercheries scientifique
du 20e siècle
un crâne humain médiévale habilement
associé à une mâchoire d'orangs outans
moderne
dès l'annoncé de sa découverte
l'authenticité du fossile fut critiquée
beaucoup y voyant une mâchoire de singes
qu'on avait assemblé à un crâne humain
sans rapport avec n
certains iront même jusqu'à suspecter
que l'articulation de la mâchoire a été
volontairement brisé afin qu'on ne
puisse pas voir qu'elle ne correspondait
pas à celle du crâne
dès 1914 des études par rayons x seront
entreprises pour vérifier l'authenticité
de certains spécimens fossiles de piles
d'armes
il faut dire que l'homme de piltdown
arrivé comme un cheveu sur la soupe
puisque avant lui le français du bois
avait déjà découvert l'homme de jab à
homo erectus tandis qu'en europe on
connaissait depuis longtemps l'homme de
néandertal et qu'on venait de découvrir
homo heidelbergensis un prêt
néandertaliens tous ces restes indiqué
que la mâchoire des hominidés s'était
d'abord réduite puis que le cerveau
s'était mis à grossir exponentiellement
après coup or l'homme de piltdown avec
sa mâchoire robuste et simiesque et son
volume crânien très gros indiquaient
tout le contraire
dès lors bien qu'il ne fût pas oublié
dans les manuels il fut néanmoins
relégué au rang de simple anomalie par
les spécialistes français et américains
de l'époque qui jugeait que l'homme de
piltdown appartenait à une lignée et
hâte et sans descendance d'hominidés il
n'y avait que les britanniques pour
défendre l'appartenance de l'homme de
piltdown dans la lignée ancestrale de
l'homme moderne
cet isolement de l'homme de piltdown a
été d'autant plus renforcée par les
découvertes d'australopithecus en
afrique du sud
en 1925 cet hominidé bien plus anciens
avaient en effet un cerveau bien plus
petit que tous les autres la supercherie
ne peut être définitivement démontré
qu'en 1953
bien après la mort de woodward et dawson
quand l'accès au matériel original et
non à des moulages ainsi que la
modernisation des techniques de datation
a permis aux sceptiques d'analysé
directement les fossiles de piltdown ces
analyses permirent de déterminer que le
crâne n'était pas un fossile mais à
crâne d'homme moderne datant du
moyen-âge et que la mâchoire appartenait
à un orang outan dont les dents avait
été mené pour ressembler à celle d'un
vieil homme
aujourd'hui s'il le faut a été révélée
il n'en demeure pas moins un mystère de
dai qui est le coupable de cette
supercherie et pourquoi at il fait ça
peut-être même était-il plusieurs en
effet près de vingt suspects et
complices potentiels ont été pointés du
doigt depuis 1953
encore aujourd'hui ces questions font
couler beaucoup d'encre et un article
publié cette année a tenté grâce à un
nouvel examen aux rayons x et à des
analyses adn et géochimiques 2
acte et reese et le mode opératoire du
ou des coupables afin de les démasquer
ces analyses ont montré que les os et
les dents ont été remplis de gravier
usées brisées est teinté afin de leur
donner l'apparence d'authentiqués
fossiles de la pâte a été utilisé pour
recoller grossièrement le tout soit au
moins trois fragments de crâne humain
différent et une mâchoire n'auront
autant comme le confirment les analyses
adn
les paléoanthropologues ont ainsi
découvert que le mode opératoire de
fabrication des faux cils était le même
pour les cils de pilotes 1
le site de découverte originel et pour
piles dans deux autres sites dont seul
le paléontologue amateur charles dawson
connaissait l'emplacement et où il avait
été le seul à fouiller par ailleurs 38
autres fossiles furent découverts dans
sa collection personnelle tous falsifiés
à peu près de la même façon enfin plus
rien n'a jamais été retrouvé à pile deux
hommes après la mort de dawson en 1916
malgré de nombreuses campagnes de
fouilles
cette nouvelle étude désigne donc dawson
comme seul et unique faussaires
néanmoins le professeur francis
thackeray paléoanthropologue en afrique
du sud a répondu à cet article en
rappelant que la mâchoire d'orangs
outans ainsi que la faune associée à
l'homme de piltdown sur le gisement et
qui comportait entre autre des restes
d'éléphants venant selon toute
vraisemblance de l'île de malte n'ont pu
être fournies que par un ou plusieurs
complices certainement des académiciens
ayant accès à des collections muséales
le conservateur du british muséum de
l'époque fut parmi les plus sérieusement
accusé de complicité par le passé mais
thackeray avancent qu'il pourrait en
fait s'agir du célèbre
paléoanthropologue et prêtre jésuite
pierre teilhard de chardin
ce dernier était en effet associé aux
fouilles de piles d'un an à l'époque et
avait même découvert l'une des canines
du célèbre canular à l'appui de cette
hypothèse de nombreuses déclarations
faites par de chardin dans ses
correspondances et notamment une date et
de l'année de la découverte de piltdown
en 1913 où il déclarait il fut un temps
où la préhistoire méritait d'être
suspecté ou plaisanté la sphère de
l'homme de piltdown est aujourd'hui
abondamment instrumentalisé par les anti
évolutionniste afin de décrédibiliser la
paléoanthropologie mais dans cette
histoire les paléoanthropologues ne se
sont pour la plupart pas fait avoir et
arthur smith woodward plutôt qu'un
coupable a été en fait le dindon de la
farce
heureusement pour sa réputation la
supercherie ne fut révélé que neuf ans
après sa mort si les motivations de 2,5
pour fabriquer un faux apparaissent
aujourd'hui évidente l'homme était en
effet connu pour ses nombreuses
tentatives d'accéder à une
connaissances scientifiques officiels
malgré sa condition d'amateurs les
motifs qui auraient poussé teilhard de
chardin à s'associer avec lui reste
floue de chardin est connu pour être un
grand défenseur d'idées qu'on associe
aujourd'hui au dessein intelligent et
peut-être son but
etait-il de se moquer ou de discréditer
les paléoanthropologues anglais ces
derniers étant un peu trop avides de
découvrir un ancêtre britannique
alors qu'on avait découvert des
hominidés partout ailleurs dans le monde
de ce point de vue tu as créé rejoint
stephen jay gould en pensant qu'il
s'agirait plutôt d'une mauvaise blague
qui aurait pris un peu trop d'ampleur et
mal tourné ainsi si les preuves
circonstancielles semble tout pointé
dans la direction d'un coupable il reste
encore à identifier son complice